we come together tonight
to imagine a future this was round
two of party conventions in the reality
tv format
enter its master and apprentice
he said everything that i could have
hoped for
they'd hired the producer of donald
trump's hit tv show
the apprentice to choreograph this
political pitch
it was a journey through trump's america
through the eyes
of trump's people growing up in the deep
south
i've seen racism up close i know what it
is
and it isn't donald trump donald trump's
quick action and leadership
saved thousands of lives during
covenanting
we may not have realized it at the time
but trump
is the bodyguard of western civilization
democrats the media and the world health
organization got coronavirus
wrong the script was every line a trump
version of past and present
the plotline this week is all about the
pivot and the polls
that he needs we have six incredible
people
donald trump appeared alongside hostages
released during his administration
then there were the mccluskies good
evening america
they're the couple who famously waved
weapons at black lives matter protesters
here given a law and order brief for the
night
what you saw happen to us could just as
easily happen to any of you
who are watching from quiet
neighborhoods around our country
republicans won't match the fame count
of the democrats last week
it's less household name more household
trump
joe biden is basically the loch ness
monster of the swamp
for the past half century he's been
lurking around in there
he sticks his head up every now and then
to run for president
then he disappears and doesn't do much
in between
at the end of his convention on thursday
there will be fireworks in washington
donald trump will deliver his nomination
acceptance speech
at the white house it will mark the end
of convention fortnight
forced onto the small screen by the
coronavirus pandemic
land of promise politics as a reality tv
contest in which we all have a stage
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
[Music]
james matthews sky news washington